sous une robe sûr sensation
bonjour et bienvenue dans une europe /
sensation une émission enregistrée au
parlement européen de bruxelles est
réalisée en association avec tv 78 voici
le sommaire de cette émission
l'eurodéputé belge marc boateng a sera
notre invité l'occasion de revenir avec
lui notamment sur la nouvelle politique
agricole commune européenne
ce jour là le 26 mai 2003 accord entre
l'union européenne et l'agencé spatiale
européenne pour le lancement du projet
de positionnement européen galileo les
superstitions en europe avec kevin
keller auteur du livre 300 une
superstition celle opportun on
s'intéressera aux superstitions liées
aux grillons mais avant que fait
l'europe dans notre région un exemple
tout de suite
saône robe l'europe dans ma région
jean monnet est l'un des pères
fondateurs de l'europe je me trouve
aujourd'hui à bazoches sur guyonne dans
les yvelines devant ce qui est à
l'époque sa résidence principale il a
vécu ici pendant près de trente ans
jusqu'à son décès on a rendez vous avec
deborah qui va nous faire une petite
visite
bonjour deborah bonjour alors expliquez
nous un peu où est-ce qu'on est
actuellement aujourd'hui vous êtes à la
maison jean monnet à bazoches sur
guyonne dans les yvelines donc c'est ici
qu'ils jean monnet avec lui de 1945
jusqu'à sa mort en 1979 on passe à la
visite bien sûr si
donc nous sommes ici de le salon de la
maison jean monnet
pour commencer cette visite je vous je
vais vous parler de la déclaration
schuman donc c'est ici que cette
déclaration a été écrite dont ces salons
même par jean monnet et ses
collaborateurs de l'éminent en 1950 et
donc c'est à travers cette déclaration
qui a été donné le coup d'envoi à la
première communauté européenne du
charbon et de l'acier très important à
7,7 cette feuille de synthèse où on
pouvoir
le déséquilibre militaire à faveur d'ela
delà des lahm allemagne nazie on peut
voir à travers
avec un coup d'oeil et effectivement la
supériorité militaire
en armement allemande donc à travers ce
feuilles de synthèse on pose par et qui
est montrée par jean monnet à au
président des états unis et roosevelt
qui convainc
roosevelt et les états unis à rentrer en
guerre donc à côté des alliés
et enfin nous nous trouvons ici de la
chambre du couple 1
ici c'est une pièce
beaucoup plus anti main on voit des des
photos familiales donc on voit jean
monnet avec sa fille marianne on voit
jamais ni avec robert schumann avec
konrad adenauer le chancelier allemand
on voit également un portrait de jean
monnet pas par sa femme simone et ça y
est la visite est terminée maintenant
place à un petit concert c'est le groupe
baroque nomade qui nous fait le plaisir
de jouer pour nous aujourd'hui ici dans
les jardins du père fondateur près d'un
hectare de terrain
[Musique]
so d'europe ce jour là
ce jour là le 26 mai 2003 l'accord entre
l'union européenne et l'agencé spatiale
européenne pour le lancement du projet
de positionnement européen galileo
retour avec europe direct et à gottfried
wilhelm leibniz philosophe allemand né
au xviie siècle affirmé que nous vivons
dans le meilleur des mondes possibles
century très optimiste nous fait sourire
nous qui vivons une drôle d'époque où
toutes nos certitudes sont remises en
question d'ailleurs même voltaire
tournait déjà en dérision century dans
son oeuvre très célèbre candide ou
l'optimisme
et bien soit nous vivons peut-être dans
le meilleur des mondes possibles
pourtant l'envi d'ailleurs fait partie
de la nature humaine les terriens
européens ne font pas exception pour
cette raison l'europe aussi s'est engagé
depuis quelques décennies dans
l'exploration de l'espace en quête de
l'inconnu
dans les années 1970 quand les
superpuissances partez à la conquête de
l'espace les états européens décidé eux
aussi d'investir pour développer leur
programme spatial civil dans cet
objectif les à agences ayant un statut
intergouvernemental a été créée par
différents pays européens
quelques années plus tard à la fin des
années 90 la commission européenne a
rendu public son projet spatial farghali
les eaux issues du programme du même nom
après quelques négociations le système
développé en collaboration avec l'agencé
spatiale européenne voyait
officiellement le jour le 26 mai 2003
est donc une date historique à retenir
puisque depuis ces deux grandes
institutions tissent des liens de plus
en plus étroit en effet déjà à l'époque
le rapprochement de lézat et de l'union
européenne à paris c'est très cohérent
étant donné que ce projet devait
répondre à des nécessités stratégique et
donc pour mettre fin à la dépendance de
l'europe vis-à-vis du système américain
gps dont galileo est l'équivalent ce
système de positionnement fait appel
tout comme le gps à une constellation de
satellites en orbite autour de la terre
pour calculer la position géographique
d'un utilisateur muni d'un terminal de
réception
dans ce cas précis le ciel nous vienne
en aide car nous pouvons bénéficier d'un
système de localisation de plus en plus
performants pour garantir la sécurité
des européens cela dit même si
l'optimisme est l'une des qualités qui
nous distingue attention vous mettez les
pieds dans tous les cas sachez que
galileo sera là pour aider les services
de secours à vous retrouver en cas de
danger imminent dans le côté européen de
la planète
zone europe l'invité politique
bonjour marque bottega bonjour vous êtes
eurodéputé belge membre du groupe de la
gauche au parlement européen nous allons
parler avec vous de la réforme de la
politique agricole commune la pac qui a
été approuvé par le parlement européen
en cette fin d'année la pac représente
presque d'un tiers du budget de l'union
européenne alors pour commencer marc
boutin gars qu'est ce qu'elle représente
pour vous cette politique agricole
commune pour moi il représente deux
choses tout d'abord un énorme espoir
parce que la politique agricole commune
canton mais un tiers du budget européen
dans une politique baisse à devrait
pouvoir permettre une bonne politique
comme une enfant faveur des agriculteurs
de l'environnement
de notre nourriture une alimentation
saine et du bien-être animal et en même
temps l agent arrive au deuxième point
une déception parce que cette pac
effectivement depuis des années des
décennies elle déçoit elle déçoit des
agriculteurs elle déçoit aussi ceux qui
veulent une alimentation saine est
meilleur dans cette politique agricole
commune elle a été lancé en 1962 c'est
un partenariat entre le secteur agricole
et la société entre l'union européenne
et les agriculteurs quelle est sa
vocation quel est son but au départ sa
vocation est multiple un don qui à la
productivité de l'agriculture il ya
garantir une alimentation un certain
prix abordables accessibles et
s'éteindre il ya différentes si on veut
différents objectifs qui sont énoncés le
grand problème a été à partir des années
90 quand en fait l'union européenne
ouvre le secteur de l'agriculture au
marché donc il ya une ouverture au
marché global les prix vont aussi évolué
avec avec le marché ce qui ne garantit
plus des prix rémunérateurs peur pour
les agriculteurs on va voir que les
quotas sucriers les pieds seront abolis
ce qui aura un impact évidemment sur les
agriculteurs dans ce secteur là et donc
on voit qu'en fait c'est de cette
ouverture au marché se fait de livrer
notre agriculture aux forces du marché
mondial va avoir un impact très négatif
sur les agriculteurs alors pour la
période 2023 2027 la pac bénéficie d'un
budget de 387 milliards d'euros dont 270
millions d'êtres direct pour les
agriculteurs pourquoi la pac
mobilise-t-elle autant d'argent est la
pac mobilise un tiers du budget européen
a plus ou moins donc un peu plus mais
pourquoi parce que l'union européenne
aujourd'hui est un
une entité si on veut un marché au
niveau mondial et où l'agriculture est
extrêmement important nous sommes en
tant qu'union européenne on peut le dire
le premier ou la première puissance ne
pas m'exprimer dans ces termes alain
mais la première puissance agricole
mondiale et il ya énormément de deux
travailleurs il ya énormément de
personnes qui dépendent eux cela
évidemment une alimentation chez nous
scène une alimentation à prix abordable
mais rémunérateurs pour les agriculteurs
et fondamentale et donc ça peut se
justifier d'avoir autant d'argent pour
une politique agricole mais alors ça
doit être mis vraiment au service d'une
part des travailleurs les agriculteurs
et d'autre part la transition climatique
ce qui est une urgence aujourd'hui et ça
on le voit pas et là effectivement on
est là avec un gros budget qui ne va pas
du tout répondre aux besoins urgents en
matière sociale et en matière climatique
alors justement ce blogueur nos
prochaines questions la nouvelle pac
voté par les députés européens pour la
période 2023 2027 vise officiellement à
développer une agriculture plus verte et
assurer une rumeur une rémunération
parlons plus juste pour les agriculteurs
est ce que cette pac permettra selon
vous de résoudre l'urgence climatique et
sociale non ça et ça c'est bien un
problème c'est la raison pour laquelle
je n'ai pas soutenu parce que on a une
urgence d'abord sociale donc en union
européenne il faut si on veut parler
chiffres de la dernière décennie plus ou
moins il ya eu environ un quart des
exploitations agricoles qui ont disparu
qui ont fermé en belgique en wallonie
que je connais un peu plus il ya ce
n'est plus considéré comme un métier
d'avenir donc les jeunes ne veulent pas
les agriculteurs à partir de 50 60 ans
qui veulent arrêter ne trouve pas
forcément de jeunes ou pas de jeunes qui
veulent reprendre et c'est donc c'est
désastreux il ya en france je sais les
suicides dans le secteur agricole qui
sont très importants et on à cette
urgence sociale et qu'est ce qu'on voit
c'est que ça on laisse le marché jouer
son rôle et 2 les pansements si on peut
dire qu'ils sont le paiement
redistributive donc ils doivent
compenser un peu ou le plafonnement des
aides à qui fait que qui devrait faire
que les grandes entreprises les grandes
exploitations agricoles ne reçoivent pas
trop de soutien par rapport aux
au petit mais émis à des niveaux
absolument absurde jean cent mille cent
mille euros qu'on plafond tandis que
chez nous par exemple les petits
agriculteurs demandait entre 50 et 60
mille euros comme plafond vous voyez
bien et quand le plafond réellement
approuvé est de plus du double enfin à
peu près le double c'est évidemment ça
ne va pas répondre aux besoins sociaux
de sexe agriculteurs la coprésidente de
votre groupe du groupe de la gauche au
parlement européen maintenant aubry a
qualifié cette pac de pâques de la honte
ou partager ce sentiment bien évidemment
je veux dire quand on a cette urgence je
parlais de l'urgence sociale pour les
agriculteurs et dans le secteur agricole
il ya l'urgence climatique d'autre part
je dis à tout le monde parle et on a
même des stratégies européennes pour
arriver à un climat comment dire pour
éviter le
le désastre et climatiques qui
s'annoncent on voit qu'on approuve en
même temps une pac qui ne répondent pas
à ça donc il ya maintenant des échos
régime dans cette pac qui devrait
garantir comment dire une transition
agroécologiques
nourriture enfin plus de nourriture
biologique etc mais on voit que s'est
mis dans une logique de concurrence et
laissé énormément aux états et donc ça
ça risque de mettre en fait de
promouvoir de stimuler le moins disant
parce que on va pas vouloir aller
beaucoup plus loin que l'autre on va
pouvoir faire mieux que l'autre si ça
coûte si ça rend ma propre moins
compétitif alors une critique qui
revient souvent sur cette taxe est qu on
offre que l'union européenne offrirait
de l'argent au lobby agroalimentaire
vous êtes d'accord avec cela c'est
surtout que les grandes les grandes
exploitations qui sont effectivement
organiser dans les meilleurs voulait
plus les lobbys les plus forts ont
obtenu gain de cause sur une série
d'éléments et donc dans ce sens là c'est
l'impact des lobbys agro alimentaire qui
ne font pas les intérêts des petits et
moyennes exploitations agricoles qui ont
prévalu effectivement dans le résultat
de cette pac est la conséquence en cela
que fondamentalement cette inégalité qui
existent aujourd'hui où 80 % des aides
vont vers les entreprises agricoles les
plus importantes et que seulement 20%
restent pour les autres mais que cette
inégalité là dans les subsides de la pac
ne sera pas résolu dans cette réforme
elle prévoit de donner davantage
d'autonomie aux états membres ce seront
eux qui auront la responsabilité de
gérer les fonds qu'ils reçoivent pour
respecter les objectifs fixés par la
commission beaucoup appellent ça une rue
nationale rue nationalisation pardon
finalement est-ce que la politique
agricole commune ne sera toujours non je
pense que on peut dire qu'ils aient
effectivement la politique agricole
commune fait un pas en arrière de ce
point de vue là et et renationaliser ya
des gens qui disent c'est très bien
parce que du coup si on veut dans notre
pays on peut faire mieux dans notre
région on peut faire mieux que le
problème c'est qu'évidemment tant qu'on
est dans une logique de marché on a mis
en concurrence avec d'autres et donc
plutôt que de dire là on peut être qu'on
veut faire mieux mais je connais des
agriculteurs qui disent on veut faire
mieux de ces drames et les régions les
gouvernements vont dire oui bah on va
pas trop en faire sur le plan social va
pas trop en faire vis-à-vis des grandes
exploitations parce que il faut qu'on
reste compétitif dans ce marché mondial
et donc la renationalisation est en fait
une exacerbation des
de la concurrence et de d'une spirale je
crains vers le bas donc vous avez appelé
sur twitter à poursuivre le combat pour
une pac catégoriquement agro écologiques
alors à quoi ressemblerait une à cette
pac pour laquelle vous vous militez je
pense que les éléments que j'ai donné
qu'ils sont focalisés sur la transition
agroécologiques donc le dire vraiment on
fait ce pari là c'est une urgence et
nous voulons aller là avec la dimension
sociale qui met les petites
exploitations
de 2
comment dire une agro écologie locale
avec une consommation plus local libérer
des forces du marché du marché mondial
qui domine les prix etc avec des prix
rémunérateurs qui fait vraiment de de
notre agriculture une profession
d'avenir le fait de pouvoir incorporer
ça dans un programme ou dans une
politique commune de un tiers du budget
européen ça me semblerait la base et
donc ça partirait pratiquement d'une
logique inverse plutôt que de pas de
parler de compétitivité etc on partir
des besoins des gens en matière
d'alimentation saine on partirait
évidemment du social comme j'ai déjà dit
mais aussi du bien être animal donc on
mettrait sa hausse entre 1 et là on
irait chercher alors les politiques et
effectivement ça ça demanderait une
rupture avec la logique du marché alors
pourtant la commission européenne
pourtant un agenda vert assez précis
c'est le fameux pacte vert européen je
pense que à la stratégie de la ferme la
fourchette notamment aussi la nouvelle
pac n'est pas en accord avec ce pacte
vert c'est le grand problème justement
des échos régime de la pac et des
objectifs votés dans la pac qui ne sont
pas compatibles avec d'autres textes
européens ou d'autres ambitions
proclamées donc c'est toujours là au
niveau européen on a on proclame souvent
des grandes des grands objectifs des
idées etc et puis la concrétisation n'y
est pas vous voyez bien quand vous avez
d'une part des belles déclarations mais
entre temps un tiers de votre budget qui
est la pac
ne correspond pas à ce que vous déclarez
ailleurs vous voyez bien qu'ils aient un
problème et ça c'est ce qui fait que
finalement la commission européenne
l'union européenne perdre crédibilité le
monde politique aussi parce que vous
faites une belle déclaration des
conférences de presse etc et après quand
il s'agit d'aider sous de l'argent de la
tum que vous mettez non vous ne
respectez pas même vos propres
déclarations je ne dis pas il peut y
avoir des désaccords politiques mais au
moins soyons en accord avec ce que vous
vous proclamé officiellement merci
d'apprécier fait un prix avec nous dans
une erreur je rappelle que vous êtes
député européen belge membre du groupe
de la gauche au parlement européen merci
zone europe / sensations
et chez nos voisins ça se passe comment
c'est notre rubrique en partenariat avec
h phie l'institut des hautes études de
journalisme de montpellier la liberté de
la presse est l'un des principes
fondamentaux des systèmes démocratiques
qui repose sur la liberté d'opinion et
la liberté d'expression reporters sans
frontières qui réalise un classement
annuel mondial sur la liberté de la
presse depuis 2002 place la france en
34e sur 180 pays évalués la pandémie
semble avoir joué un grand rôle dans les
conditions de travail des journalistes
qui sont confrontés à une fermeture des
accès au terrain aux sources
d'information jeu à la crise sanitaire
selon rsf c'est que nous et censure
représente un obstacle majeur à cette
liberté de la presse le nzd montre que
le journalisme est totalement ou
partiellement bloquées dans 73% des pays
évalués mais qu'en est-il dans les pays
voisins même si l'europe demeure en tête
du classement les états membres
affichent de fortes disparités si les
pays scandinaves sont parmi les mieux
classés dans le monde ce n'est pas le
cas de la plupart des pays
méditerranéens et d'europe de l'est mais
le continent reste le plus favorable à
la liberté de la presse en dépit des
politiques répressives de certains pays
de l'union européenne et des balkans
selon les ong parmi les dix pays du
monde où la liberté de la presse est la
mieux garantis sept d'entre eux sont
européens la finlande est deuxième du
classement le danemark troisième la
suède 4e les pays-bas 5e et le portugal
10e à noter que la norvège conserve sa
première place et que la suisse occupe
la 8ème position néanmoins en allemagne
qui est 11e et la france 34e les
journalistes sont de plus en plus
l'objet de violences lors de
manifestations
en europe la liberté de la presse est
également mise en danger par des
procédures d'intimidation politiques et
judiciaire lancée contre les
journalistes le rapport annuel de la
plateforme du conseil de l'europe pour
la protection du journaliste et la
sécurité des journalistes s'alarme sur
la situation de la liberté de la presse
bien au delà de la france le document
officiel indique d'ailleurs dans son
titre adressé aux politiques européens
que des actions concrètes s'imposent
pour garantir la liberté des médias en
europe
zone europe voyage
on en vient maintenant à notre rubrique
voyager dans l'assiette une nouvelle
recette tout de suite aujourd'hui je
vous présentais une recette est
emblématique de sa la team qui a fait un
peu la renommée de ce restaurant c'est
le ch ni de sel c'est une escalope de
poulet pané qui est un peu la recette de
ma maman des escalopes de poulet
on va retrouver du sel dits gousses
d'ail une cuillère à café de moutarde
une cuillère à soupe de concentré de
tomate du poivre du vinaigre et des
oeufs et pour terminer de la chapelure
de pain d'accord qui est déjà un petit
peu assaisonner avec des graines de
sésame on va commencer par la viande le
poulet d'accord on utilise du blanc de
poulet simple fermier moi j'aime bien
montrer un petit techniques sont
d'accord donc là c'est un filet entier
la première étape c'est d'enlever le
petit filet
du grand filet tout simplement à la main
ensuite on va 1,6 et en plein milieu
sans aller jusqu'au bout
d'accord et là c'est la technique en
fait on va escaloper
le blanc de poulet d'accord mon côté fin
et un côté épais comme ça vous avez le
croustillant et aussi le côté charnue
du blanc de poulet notaire notre mélange
de
donc on va utiliser pour cela un oeuf
à commencer par le battre
et on va y mettre un peu de poivre noir
[Musique]
un petit peu de sel
on va mettre
donc là ça va servir sur aussi de
marinade donc déjà c'est honnêtement
nous escalopes à l'intérieur et on va
tout mélanger
cette réparation un peu fait d'avery si
vous voulez laisser à aromatiser vos
escalopes
sinon quelques minutes suffisent arrive
l'étape où on va pas nés les escalopes
où on va les enrobés de chapelure de
pain qui est mélangée avec du sésame du
poivre du sel donc une cuillère à soupe
de beurre à café de sel une cuillère à
café de poivre une cuillère à café de
paprika rouge
et un peu de die en poule face à lens et
des mamans
délicatement enlever l'excédent neuf
et on va les plonger dans un produit du
temps d'un côté
et ensuite de l'autre bien faire de la
chapelure s'accroche bien sûr le tout
poussez surface
une surface égale
et on va les poser dans l'assiette
on va bien faire attention qui la
chapelure partout
on va que dans une poêle avec de l'huile
de tournesol 2 minutes de chaque côté
dans une poêle j'aime et de l'huile
un fond d'huile mais quand même environ
2,3 bon verre d'huile de tournesol
qui a permet de cuire uniformément
l'escalope de poulet et pendant ce temps
là on va faire la sauce
pour la sauce ont fait une dérive et de
la mayonnaise on va prendre comme pour
la mayonnaise
que les jaunes d'oeuf
on va en 32
on va clarifier
les jeunes
le premier et deuxième masse
de la moutte à
une cuillère à café et on va commencer
par gentiment battre la moutarde et les
jaunes d'oeuf
pour deux jaunes d'oeuf je met
l'équivalent de 500 mille litres d'huile
de tournesol
trouvait la base de votre mayonnaise
ensuite
je prends mon vinaigre une pincée de sel
je vais faire fondre le sel dans le
vinaigre pour pouvoir assaisonner
la sauce avec
non je verse délicatement
l'équivalent d'une cuillère à café
du pain c'est de concentrer thomas
dedans petit peu de poivre
est en fait une fois
une demi gousse d'ail
pour bien saisir la chapelure et éviter
que l'huile pénètre à l'intérieur que ça
devienne une escalope trop grasse donc
c'est très important vaut mieux attendre
deux trois minutes supplémentaires pour
ce soit bien chaud et que ça puisse
cuire rapidement
l'escalope de poulet on va plonger les
escalopes une à une
délicatement
donc là on va laisser cuire environ 2
minutes de chaque côté donc deux minutes
on va les retourner et laissait encore
deux minutes et après on va préparer un
petit bac avec du papier sopalin pour
absorber l'excédent d'huile
je vais aussi faire épiler les grandes
escalopes
on est pas mal on va retourner
on va les retirer les petits mais bodian
nous ne reste plus qu'a dressé
ensuite on va disposer par dessus
les escalopes
et ensuite on va mettre les branches de
coriandre par dessus et de la fleur de
sel
donc voilà je vous présente la recette
des chenilles de celle de maintenant
c'est des escalopes de poulet pané qui
ont bercé mon enfance
c'est des escalopes de poulet qui sont
pas nés avec une chapelure légèrement
assaisonnés avec des graines de sésame
et des épices et qui va être frais d'une
certaine façon qui va pas être trop
grasse et qui va être très légère
expansion
sous une robe sûr sensation
les superstitions en europe avec kevin
keller auteur du livre 300 une
superstition petite encyclopédie des
peurs et sagesse populaire celle
opportun on s'intéresse cette semaine
aux grillons le grillon le grillon et
forcé porté bonheur toujours hérité de
la tradition paysanne donc à petit
grillon qui rentre de lui-même dans une
maison ces bonheurs pour la maison on va
se rendre compte que dans le midi par
exemple les provençaux ou vont accrocher
une cigale en céramique à l'entrée de
leur maison mais ils vont faire entrer
mais un petit grillon en cage qu'ils
vont élever dans la maison pour que le
grillon soit là et porte chance zone
europe c'est terminé pour aujourd'hui
merci aux équipes techniques du
parlement européen de bruxelles vous
pouvez retrouver cette émission en
podcast audio et vidéo sur notre site et
notre application radio sensations et
aussi sur tv 78 rendez vous la semaine
prochaine très bonne soirée
sonne robe sûr sensation
zone europe avec le soutien financier de
la région ile de france